PETER LUBBERS: Hello
and welcome to
Google Developers Live.
You're on the Chrome channel.
I'm Peter Lubbers and with me
today I have special guest
Addy Osmani, who's a developer
programs engineer in the
Google Chrome Developer
relations team.
Addy, how are you?
ADDY OSMANI: I'm good, thanks.
PETER LUBBERS: Right, right.
So today we're really excited
to talk about Yeoman.
There's been a lot of buzz
around it already.
It was announced a couple weeks
ago at Google I/O by
Paul Irish.
And Addy is one of the main
contributors of the
tool/workflow optimization.
And we want to talk a little
bit more about that today.
Addy's going to give
us a demo, talk a
little bit about it.
We have the moderator
questions as well.
A lot of you have sent your
questions in, we've had
hundreds of votes already
on those questions.
So we'll go through
all of that.
Total time will be about an
hour, and let's dive right in.
So Addy, what--
first of all, the pronunciation,
is It "Yo-man?"
ADDY OSMANI: Yes,
that's perfect.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, perfect.
What exactly does Yeoman
do and how does it
help me as a developer?
ADDY OSMANI: So Yeoman is an
opinionated workflow for
creating web applications.
And when we created it, we took
a look at the way that
developers are currently
creating web apps.
And they're spending
quite a lot of time
on things like process.
They're spending a lot of time
trying to figure out what
tools they should be using,
getting those tools into
things like a build process,
and testing harnesses, and
stuff like that.
And then they're spending
a lot of time writing
boilerplate code when they
want to start using a
particular framework.
For example, NBC Frameworks.
And we thought about how we
could possibly, perhaps bring
a whole set of opinionated
tools together and give
developers a single option
that works well and has
everything set up for them so
they can spend less time on
process and a little bit more
time focusing on the logic for
their apps.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
So how did you come
up with the name?
ADDY OSMANI: So Paul Irish
thought up the name on his way
out of the bathroom
one day and--
[LAUGHTER]
ADDY OSMANI: They had a vote
about what name to go for.
It wasn't initially the most
popular name, the other one
was WebApp Boilerplate.
But we figured there were a
few too many boiler plate
projects out there
at the moment.
And Yeoman was a good fit.
So Yeoman in Old English times
was a servant to the sovereign
that would perform a number of
different tasks for them.
And we thought, that's
a pretty good fit,
and the name stuck.
PETER LUBBERS: Excellent,
excellent.
I like the new logo for it.
So is it at the high level,
is it easy install, to get
started with it?
How does that work?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeoman takes just
a few minutes to install.
And once it's done for the first
time, you don't have to
do that again.
You can easily start using
it to create projects.
Whenever you're working with
particular dependencies,
whether it be Twitter
Bootstrap, or HTML5
Boilerplate, when we fetch
those, we actually catch them.
So the time taken to actually
get those things is really
only in the first instance.
Every single other time we're
just fetching it from cache
and we provide you ways to
update those if you want to.
But getting started
is extremely easy.
Anybody can get started
in just a few minutes.
It's a fairly easy tool
to use, I think.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
Now you say anybody, so is
it available for Windows?
I think a lot of the demos
I saw were Ma-based.
What's the latest on that?
ADDY OSMANI: At the moment
we're targeting nix-based
environments.
We do have Windows on our sites
and we're hoping to
target Windows users with the
next version of the projects.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
Now tell me a little bit before
we get into an actual
look of it.
Tell me a little bit about
the current status of it.
It was announced at I/O, what's
the current status, how
can you get involved with it?
ADDY OSMANI: So the project
was announced
at I/O, as you mentioned.
And we've spent a few weeks
refactoring it and getting a
few new ideas into
the project.
One that we're really excited
about is the concept of
generators.
For anybody that's used Ruby on
Rails before, you might be
familiar with their
generator system.
And we thought it would be
pretty cool if we were able to
bring that to front-end
development so that developers
don't have to spend that
much time running
boiler place code.
And they can say I was to use a
particular framework, maybe
there's a Yeoman scaffold
available for it and I can
start writing out my project
logic without having to do all
the other manual plumbing that
I'd normally have to.
So we've been working on that.
We've been working on tidying
up the rest of the project,
making sure it is as
stable as possible.
And yeah, I'll hopefully
be showing you some
of that stuff today.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, excellent,
excellent.
Well, how about maybe you
can share your demo
with us and we can--
ADDY OSMANI: Absolutely.
PETER LUBBERS: --dive
right into it.
So let's take a look at it.
ADDY OSMANI: Certainly.
PETER LUBBERS: What have
you got there?
ADDY OSMANI: OK, so we're going
to start off with a
command prompt.
So Yeoman supports a few
different commands and you can
access the list of
these using Help.
And the list you'll see at the
moment includes Init for
initializing scaffolding
projects using our generators.
Build for building an optimized
version of your project.
Server, Test, and a few
others that I'll talk
about in a few minutes.
Now the basic idea that we
showed in the first video
about Yeoman was that you could
pick off a project using
Yeoman Init.
Now over the past couple of
weeks, because we've been
writing this generator system,
we figured well, why isn't
Init also just another
scaffold?
And so when we kick start this
off to create a new project,
what you'll see is that you
get a welcome prompt.
This is a scaffold, anybody can
go create their own one.
They can include their own ASVR,
their own dependencies
and things.
There's already a project in
here at the moment, so I'm
going to say Force, and it's now
going to ask me what I'd
like to include in
the project.
So here, in this particular
scaffold, we're going to by
default include HTML5
Boilerplate and Twitter Bootstrap.
We find that quite a lot of
developers use those regularly.
But we thought, let's ask them
if they'd also like to include
the Twitter Bootstrap plug-ins,
the jQuery plug-ins
in case they perhaps want
to use those too.
You can then go and
configure options.
And we'll then go and pull the
latest versions of the HTML5
Boilerplate projects, Compass
Bootstraps so you can edit the
Twitter Bootstrap
source files.
And we'll also set up a test
harness for Jasmine so you can
start writing unit tests.
Now I'm going to show
you something I
think is pretty cool.
I have to switch windows
very quickly, a second.
So we just generated a directory
containing a bunch
of different files.
And the index file that's
created will look quite
familiar to people who've used
HTML5 Boilerplate before.
And when we go through it, you
see that it's fairly regular
until we get to the very end.
And in the end you see this
block-- let me zoom in a
little bit so it's bit
easier to read.
PETER LUBBERS: Thanks.
ADDY OSMANI: So this is a really
interesting block.
This code right around it, it's
an HTML comment, this is
a decorative way we've invited
people to define what final
output file you would like all
of the files inside a block to
get concatenated and
minified into.
So rather than you having to
go and set up any of this
stuff inside a configuration
file, you can configure where
any block of scripts finally
gets output to using your
HTML, which we thought
was quite fun.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah,
that's great.
ADDY OSMANI: What this actually
provides you with is
fairly basic.
Let's go back to the command
prompt very, very quickly.
One second.
Let's clear this out.
Now when you want to get a
dependency for a project,
whether it be jQuery, or
Backbone, or something else,
you'll either go to GitHub and
try to get the latest version
of the project, or you'll go the
project's homepage and get
the latest version
that they've made
available through there.
That involves opening up a web
browser and doing quite a few
manual steps to get
it and then saving
it locally, et cetera.
We thought well, systems like
NPM are really, really nice to
pull packages down from.
Why don't we provide developers
with something a
little bit similar?
So if I, for example, wanted
to go get a dependency, I
already have jQuery in this
project, but let's say I
wanted to grab it anyway.
I can simply go and do Yeoman,
Install, jQuery.
It'll check our registry for
that and if it finds it, it'll
simply fetch it and provide
you with a local version.
That's very, very simple.
You didn't have to go to open
up a web browser or do
anything else.
If I wanted to include something
let's say, Backbone,
it's a very, very
similar process.
Split second, you've
got the dependency.
And this isn't just going and
fetching you Backbone.
It's resolving all the different
dependencies that a
particular library
might also need.
So Backbone, for example, will
need jQuery itself and it will
also need Underscore.
We've actually gone and fetched
those for you when you
did Yeoman, Install, Backbone.
So it's very, very easy to go
and start using libraries in
your project regardless of
whether they have a ton of
dependencies themselves
or not.
Another really interesting thing
that I'd like to show
you is an example of another
type of Yeoman generator.
When I mentioned earlier on on
Twitter, I think a week or two
ago, that we were working on
this generator system, quite a
few people, and I think on the
moderator queue as well--
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: --were asking are
we going to support Ember, are
we going to support Backbone
and Angular, and all these
other frameworks?
And I'll talk a little bit about
for a moment, second.
Let's switch back
to the terminal.
So I've scaffolded out a
very basic project now.
If I want to start using a
library like Backbone and I
want to not have to write all
the boilerplate code for my
models and my collections and
my other bits and pieces, I
can go and do Yeoman,
Init, Backbone, All.
And that will automatically go
and create me a scaffolded
version of my application.
Now I'm going to run this
in just a second.
Generators are really
interesting.
They don't just support
scaffolding
out an entire project.
Every single part of a framework
that we have
scaffolded out is considered
a sub-generator.
So if you wanted to generate a
new model, all I have to is
Backbone, Model, and
then my model name.
The exact same thing with
a view or a collection.
And that would work as well.
For this case, I want to
basically create all of them
just for our demo.
And I know that I'm going to be
overwriting some existing
files and so I'm going to pass
the Force flag in there.
And very, very quickly it's gone
and it's created a bunch
of different directories
for my application--
models, collections,
views, routes--
that are going to be needed by
the additional files that this
particular framework uses.
And I've got--
I can't tell if you can see
the highlights of--
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah,
I can see them.
ADDY OSMANI: I've got my
application view, I've got a
template for the view, I've got
a model created, I've got
a collection created.
And we can go and inspect
one of these files.
So if we were to go to Apps.js
views, application view, take
a look at that.
It's actually scaffolded out an
extremely basic view that
we can use.
Now, if I very quickly show you
something else, I'm going
to skip right back to the prompt
very quickly to show
you the built-in Yeoman
server task.
Oh, let's see.
So when I preview this
application in a second.
[TYPING]
There we go.
All right.
So if I do Yeoman server, now.
And I'll need to--
pardon me for having to switch
through so many windows.
PETER LUBBERS: No problem.
What does the Yeoman
server do?
ADDY OSMANI: So Yeoman server
basically kicks off a local
http server that you can use
preview your application.
And when you run that, we go and
we automatically compile
all of your CoffeeScript files,
all of your Compass
files, and any other files that
might need a level of
compilation in them to provide
you with an intermediate view
of your application.
Consider it something a little
close to production-level
build, but not quite there in
case you want to still edit
some source files and make
other changes before we
optimize everything.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
What server are you using for it
now, or is it configurable?
ADDY OSMANI: It's
configurable.
We're also tying this in to the
Yeoman Watch Task, which
again, does a very
similar thing.
If you make changes to your
Compass or CoffeeScript files.
It'll automatically go and
compile those files for you so
your preview is constantly up to
date without you having to
go and manually do anything.
PETER LUBBERS: Excellent,
excellent.
Wow.
ADDY OSMANI: Now let me take
you to the preview.
Now you be seeing the
window that's barely
playing at the moment.
There's nothing really in there,
but there's actually--
that's our application.
It's a very blank-looking
window.
But you go to the development
tools, and what you see--
I'm not sure if anybody can see
this, but there's a line
that says, hello
from Backbone.
PETER LUBBERS: Yep.
ADDY OSMANI: And if we flip back
to Sublime very quickly,
I think [INAUDIBLE] the code.
Just a second.
I'll take you through
the code.
So we've got an application
view.
Myapp.js is basically a file
which contains the initial
part of your application.
It contains the name, space,
generation stuff.
So here for example, I'm
defining my name space.
Where do I want my models,
inflections and other bits and
pieces to go.
And you can also see an Init
function here, which just
says, hello from Backbone on
the console when it is
correctly loaded up.
And that means that everything
is working correctly.
Backbone's properly loaded
up and everything from a
scaffolding point of view
more or less works.
But that's boring.
What if we were to go to our
application view and stick
something a little more
interesting in there.
I wrote a very, very quick
Backbone application a few
minutes ago.
All it's doing is we're working
against the body.
This is a self-rendering view.
And we're going to pin some
content to it when the view
gets initialized.
So I'm updating the
names spaces
that I'm working against.
And I'm going to return back
now to a preview window.
[TYPING]
ADDY OSMANI: Just a second.
And what you should see now
is Yeoman with hello
developers in there.
And we;ve got a view
that's working.
We've got a very, very simple
application, but an
application that's
working as well.
That's all fine.
But people probably also
interested in things like the
build process.
PETER LUBBERS: Right, right.
There have been a couple of
questions online about the
build process as well.
So yeah, step us through
that a little bit.
By the way, is that related to
the HTML5 Boilerplate build
process that you said was
already included in that?
ADDY OSMANI: So what we've done
is the node-build-script
project is part of the HTML5
Boilerplate umbrella of projects.
And that's a part of Yeoman.
We've taken a look at how to
redo that as better as we can.
And we've built a lot
on top of that to--
PETER LUBBERS: OK, great.
ADDY OSMANI: --a little
bit better.
Michael Daniels is the guy that
maintains that project
and he's on the Yeoman team,
which has been really, really
helpful for us.
So I'm going to quickly
take you through the
Yeoman build process.
So very similar to the other
commands, when I do Yeoman
build, it's going to go now
and build up the project.
It's concatenating all the
script's, it's minifying
everything, and it's producing
an optimized
version of your project.
Somebody earlier was asking on
the moderator queue, do we
support file versioning.
Take a look at some of the file
names that are initially
being generated in one of
the intermediate steps.
The answer to that
is yes, we do.
We do support file versioning.
And so what is the Yeoman
build process
actually doing for you?
We'll talk about that
very quickly.
So when you start building a
project, the first thing we're
going to do is actually see if
there's any optimizations we
can make to the scripts
and the CSS files.
What needs to be compiled?
Again, we're talking about
Compass and CoffeeScript.
We're then going to
take a look at the
images in your project.
We spent quite a lot of time
taking a look at image
compression and we benchmarked
a lot of the solutions that
are out there at the moment
for making the small size
images with as little lost
quality as possible.
And that's essentially
what we're going to
do with your project.
We're going to go through all
of your images, and produce
optimal versions of them
that hopefully take up
less space as well.
We're then going to optimize
the rest of your payload,
regenerate you an application
cache manifest.
That's something that sometimes
developers that are
interested and take a look at
offline have challenges with
because not everybody
knows the structure
to a manifest file--
PETER LUBBERS: Yep.
ADDY OSMANI: --and sometimes
end up having to go back to
different articles to try
figuring out OK, how should it
properly be done?
With Yeoman we automatically
generate one of those for you.
PETER LUBBERS: And you can
configure it like you did in,
for example, in Boilerplate?
That was a real huge time saver,
or aggravation saver,
rather, because you have to
always update that manifest
file and if you forget
it, then--
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: Perfect,
perfect.
ADDY OSMANI: And we've of
course-- it looks like the
lights have been turned off
here very, very quickly.
I'm going to go activate them.
Sorry about that.
PETER LUBBERS: No problem.
ADDY OSMANI: We're also going
to do things like run all of
your unit tests through
PhantomJS, which is going to
be doing the headless Webkit
testing for you.
Another nice thing about the
Yeoman generator is that we're
going to hopefully encourage
more developers to do, is to
include automatic scaffolding
for basic unit
tests to do the framework.
So the Backbone one, or perhaps
an Ember one, or an
AngularJS one, if you started
creating a model, wouldn't it
be really cool if it also
created a scaffold for your
unit tests to go with you?
And we're taking a look
at that right now.
We're hopeful that the
generators that we include out
of the box with Yeoman are going
to include unit test
scaffolds so that people
can take a
look at them for reference.
And we hope that we can do our
part to encourage developers
to give unit testing a really
hard thing because it is an
important part of the whole
process at the end of the day.
Other than that, that's it
for the build process.
There are few other minor
optimizations we make to your
files, but that's really it.
We have a few other commands
that help you search through
the registry for different
dependencies you might need
and other helpful [INAUDIBLE]
unit testing.
But I'm going to very quickly
show you an example of a
Yeoman generator.
This is probably the first
public code for Yeoman.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
Excellent.
ADDY OSMANI: Let me see if
I can pull it up quickly.
OK.
So you might remember the
Initial prompt that I showed
you at the start where we asked
you if you'd like to
include the Twitter Bootstrap
plug-ins and if you'd like to
do one or two other things.
Now the come for that is hooking
into our generator API
and our prompts API.
And we provided developers with
a really, really rich API
for doing anything they
want with generators.
If you want to create a
generator that depends on some
different assets from Github or
through your site or from
different servers.
We're going to support
allowing you to
easily pull those in.
If you want to easily
wire things up.
So if you downloaded perhaps an
entire repository as a part
of your dependencies and you
only want to filter out a few
files or perhaps you only want
to include a few files in the
user's index, the user's app,
we give you easy methods to
let you do those things.
And there's a ton of different
helpers in place to help you
achieve a lot of the tasks that
I think developers that
want to write generators are
going to want to do.
I think one of the moderator
questions was, is Yeoman going
to include all these
generators for--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah, they gave
us one from Yunkeltron from
New Haven, so--
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah, what work
has been done on generators
front, and what will the
integration look like with
respect to community
contributed?
ADDY OSMANI: I think what Yeoman
will probably do is
we'll probably give developers
one or two really, really good
scaffolds right out
of the box.
And we might start maintaining a
few others like experimental
ones from Backbone and
another frameworks
outside of the project.
But we're going to work with
different people in the
community, hopefully framework
authors, and develop the best
set of generators hopefully.
That maybe community driven and
can include all the best
practices that particular
frameworks need to use.
And hopefully that'll give
people some want to start
creating whole communities and
whole sites full of generators
that you can easily share
with other people.
If somebody doesn't like a
particular generator and wants
to easily customize it and do
other things, they've got
entire API to play around with
that they can use to do that.
And yeah, I mean it's
extremely simple.
Here for example is some code
that is manually wiring in a
bunch of scripts to do with the
Twitter Bootstrap plug-ins.
We also offer ways of pending
entire directories of scripts,
for example, in this thing
that I've highlighted.
It works really, really well
with AMD for people who like
to use RequireJS and AMD modules
in their setups.
And we've tried to be as
comprehensive as possible with
what Yeoman lets developers
achieve.
I don't think that there's
a popular set up that the
project isn't going to support
out of the box.
PETER LUBBERS: Great, great.
Fantastic.
So should we take a look at a
couple of the questions from
the moderator?
ADDY OSMANI: Absolutely.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, great.
Well one of the questions and
some of them you've obviously
answered, but we'll
step through them.
So the question is, when
will Yeoman be
available for testing?
You touched on this a little
bit already but
maybe just to reiterate.
This is from Mike from Denver.
ADDY OSMANI: We currently
have a private
beta open at the moment.
Yeoman's been getting, quite
thankfully, a lot of attention.
We had 6,000 or 7,000 people
sign up for the beta in the
first few days that
it was announced.
And so we, of course, haven't
been able to let everybody in
just yet, but we're slowly
including more and more people
as we get closer to
an actual release.
And we're hopeful that we'll be
able to get a release out
for everybody to try out in
I think maybe, two weeks.
So at the end of the
month, hopefully.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, excellent.
ADDY OSMANI: End of the month,
start of next month.
But yeah, it should be soon.
PETER LUBBERS: And they can
follow @Yeoman on Twitter?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
PETER LUBBERS: You have a
Google+ page as well?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
All the links to our pages are
on Yeoman.I/O, and any
information about the project
that we'll be posting whether
it's previews of ideas that
we're trying out, or things
that are definitely going to
be in a project that we've
implemented and are going to be
coming close to a release
date, those will all be on
Twitter or Google+ page and we
encourage people to
check those out.
PETER LUBBERS: Excellent.
So another question from
Mooseman on the internet.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: Can I use Yeoman
for minification,
optimization of existing or
my already built project?
That's actually interesting,
right, because you might--
I was thinking about the same
thing, oh, I'd like to get
that on an existing project.
Is that possible?
ADDY OSMANI: So as of today,
it isn't just yet.
But we are working this
week on ways that we
can make that happen.
It's really a case of just
making sure that a few
specific configuration files
get written into your
directory without overriding
anything else going on in your
application.
But it should be--
I think it's something we're
going to aim to get in place
before our launch.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, great.
Yeah, there was another question
like it so-- that's
from Dylan Green, so that's
the same answer.
What about plans for
documentation generation like,
for example, Doco.
It's a question from
Millie Yell.
ADDY OSMANI: So we don't
currently have an automatic
documentation generation
task in place just yet.
But I did read that question the
other day and I thought,
that's a really cool idea.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: And so we've
started discussions on maybe
using Doco or another
solution.
Whether that's something that
makes it into the first
version of the project I'm not
sure, but it's definitely
something that we're looking
at the moment and it might
make its way into Yeoman
in the future.
PETER LUBBERS: Perfect,
perfect.
So then a question
from Guario.
What kind of NVC generators
will you
include at the launch?
So you mentioned already, you
mentioned the architecture,
but to check on that again, so
what does the current plan as
mentioned, Backbone,
Ember, Knockout?
ADDY OSMANI: So I think what
we'll probably do there, and
we haven't got a firm plan for
this just yet, but we'll
probably do is have community
maintained Yeoman generators
for things like Backbone
and Ember.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
ADDY OSMANI: We do have
proof of concepts in
place at the moment.
I was showing you the
Backbone one.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
ADDY OSMANI: We've also got a
proof of concept of the Ember
one and an AngularJS one.
And a few for other
frameworks.
And what we want to make sure
of is that obviously, we do
have some experience with these
other frameworks, but
the people using them, the
framework authors are going to
be the ones that know exactly
what should be going into a
proper Boilerplate scaffold.
And we'd like to work with those
people perhaps to get
the best set of generators
done.
And maybe they'll be better
people to maintain them.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah,
exactly, exactly.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeoman out of the
box, I think we'll try to get,
we might try to get an AngularJS
one done included in
the release.
But other than that,
it's going to be
community-maintained generators
for everything else.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, excellent,
excellent.
Now there's a question from
Current in Vancouver.
Any plans for a native live
reload functionality that
isn't dependent on live
reload itself?
What do you have for
live reloading?
ADDY OSMANI: So you can use
live reload if you have it
installed and you prefer
to use that system.
We do recommend people
try that.
But we've got a fallback that
will work pretty much in any
browser that will automatically
refresh your
page if you make
changes to it.
It's not as good as the live
reload one, which is why we
recommend using that.
But we do have a cross-browser
solution in place.
So yes, I guess is the answer.
PETER LUBBERS: Great, great.
Another question from K Lenny.
Would it be possible to use
Yeoman with something like
EmberJS or Meteor?
Now you mentioned Ember already,
but any Meteor
integration?
ADDY OSMANI: I guess it is the
same thing that I would say
about any other framework.
We're going to provide
developers with all of the
APIs that they need to write
generators to work with any
frameworks.
Whether it's Ember, or Meteor,
or something else, it should
be possible to write
a scaffold that
will work with it.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Perfect.
I think a couple
more questions.
Is Yeoman using NPM for
package management?
Or what is it using
on their covers?
Levvy Dehon was asking that.
ADDY OSMANI: So for our
own [INAUDIBLE]
of some known dependencies, we
are using NPM for that, but
what we have for everything
else, what you saw me doing
when I was coding in jQuery and
Backbone, I was using a
project by Twitter which hasn't
been released yet
called Bower.
And Bower is another package
management solution.
PETER LUBBERS: How do
you spell that?
ADDY OSMANI: So it's
B-O-W-E-R.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, OK.
ADDY OSMANI: The idea there is,
it's going to be another
registry, but one which
framework authors and library
authors and people that do
create different scripts to be
used by other people can
easily push too.
It's easy to use and as you saw
with Yeoman, it's fairly
easy to replicate some of
the stuff that NPM does.
Easily installing a dependency,
searching for it
or resolving the other bits and
pieces that it might need.
PETER LUBBERS: Perfect,
perfect.
So one of the questions you
already answered in your
earlier demo was the automated
final versioning.
And this was from Mike
in New York.
Any plans to add automated
file versioning?
CheckSum added it as
a query parameter.
But you mentioned that you were
thinking about that or
will that also make it into--
ADDY OSMANI: That's
already in place.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, OK.
Fantastic, fantastic.
Well, let's see.
In the event of Yeoman's success
and popularity, how
soon can we expect Yeoman swag?
[LAUGHTER]
ADDY OSMANI: That's
a good question.
We're currently working on
swag and you can probably
expect to see some in the
very near future.
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
Well that's about a serious
as the other question from
Charles of when can I get paid?
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: So in all
seriousness, where can people--
you mentioned that Yeomon.I/O
is the main site.
From there, they can
follow you along.
If you wanted to add your name
to the list of the private
beta, is that still possible?
ADDY OSMANI: You can currently
do that through Yeoman.I/O. As
I mentioned, for people that
are interested in either
helping out with the product
or really testing it out to
it's limits, we are letting a
few people in right now as
part of the private beta.
We will be opening Yeoman out
to the public in the next
couple of weeks hopefully.
And yeah, Yeoman.I/O is going
to be the place to be.
That's where we're going to
launch the whole new website,
the holding page is going to go
and everything is going to
be up there, from the
documentation to
where you can get it.
PETER LUBBERS: Fantastic.
Great, so well I think, did you
have any other facts or
tips and tricks to
share with us?
Or I think that's pretty
much it, right?
ADDY OSMANI: I think that's
pretty much it.
Please be sure to follow us on
Twitter or Google+ and yeah,
Yeoman should be out soon.
PETER LUBBERS: Fantastic,
fantastic.
Well thank you so much
for the great demo.
We'll take care of the--
I think we took care of
all the questions.
If we didn't, then my apologies
and we'll answer
them offline, And check out
Yeoman.I/O for all of the
information.
Sign up there for the private
beta and that's it.
Thank you for joining and
until next time, thanks.
Thanks, Addy.
ADDY OSMANI: Thanks.